[Musik]
hallo ich heiße maja monster ich bin
eine journalistin aus aktiv ich bin nach
lemberg geflohen nach den ersten bomben
die wir im keller abgewartet haben war
ich gezwungen verwandte und kinder erst
aktiv zu evakuieren
wir hoffen dass unsere partner uns
helfen diesen idioten diesen feind putin
zu stoppen damit wir in der zukunft
friedlich und ruhig leben können sie
will die meisten einwohner hier sind in
schutzräumen oder in ihren häusern
wir freuen uns auf den moment in dem
alles wieder in frieden endet
ja stimmen die so wichtig sind in diesem
krieg geben weil sie dessen
leidtragenden ein gesicht geben den
menschen gehör verleihen denen putin
einen krieg aufzwingt den sie nicht
gewollt haben und damit herzlich
willkommen zu diesem zdf spezial wir
zählen tag 5 und ahnen schon jetzt dass
sich noch unzählige tage hinzu gesellen
könnten bis die waffen schweigen und
frieden einzug hält in der ukraine nur
wann wird das sein und was für ein
frieden wäre das überhaupt ein kalter
frieden in einem unfreien von russland
beherrschten vasallenstaat oder wäre das
ein wahrer friede in einer unabhängigen
ukraine einen funken hoffnung versprühen
die verhandlungen an der belarussischen
grenze gegen mittag deutscher zeit haben
sie begonnen bisher ohne ergebnis und
auch ohne feuerpause in einer ungleichen
schlacht
ein sechsjähriges mädchen das durch
einen russischen angriff
lebensgefährlich verletzt worden sein
soll wird ins krankenhaus in mario pohl
eingeliefert
ärzte und schwestern kämpfen um ihr
leben und
verlieren auch
hier bangen sie um ihre kinder ein
fitnessstudio in mariupol etliche
familien haben hier unterschlupf
gefunden menschen zwischen verzweiflung
und hoffnung
möge gott verhindern dass uns hier
raketen treffen wir haben uns hier
versammelt weil wir hier die menschen
mit allem versorgen können inklusive
lebensmittel menschen kommen und bringen
was gebraucht wird
es ist tag fünf der russischen invasion
und die ukrainische armee leistet weiter
erbitterten widerstand
russland hat nicht damit gerechnet dass
wir so stark sind aber wir ukraine haben
diese geschichte verändert die eu hat
entschieden uns waffen zu liefern dafür
sind wir dankbar im osten der ukraine
jedoch scheinen die prorussischen
separatisten land zu gewinnen
unsere armee ist auf dem vormarsch der
widerstand wird weniger die verluste
beim feind werden größer wir werden dann
jetzt und lohans komplett befreien und
der ukraine frieden bringen
immerhin in kiew soll die vergangenen
nacht relativ ruhig gewesen seien
explosionen und schüsse haben offenbar
etwas nachgelassen und dennoch sind die
straßen am morgen verweist in der nacht
noch hatte bürgermeister vitali
klitschko die bewohner gewarnt
unsere verteidiger bereiten sich darauf
vor unsere hauptstadt zu beschützen
jeder in kiew sollte die nacht im bunker
verbringen der feind bombardiert weiter
unsere häuser und die zivile
infrastruktur aber er leidet auch
heftigen verluste
nach ukrainischen angaben wurden bisher
4500 russische soldaten getötet
überprüfen lässt sich diese zahl nicht
dieses video wurde von der ukrainischen
armee veröffentlicht es soll einen
drohnenangriff auf einen russischen
raketenwerfer zeigen
es gibt meldungen dass die russische
offensive an tempo verloren hat offenbar
auch weil die gegenwehr heftig ist im
ganzen land bereiten sich die menschen
auf die verteidigung vor zivilisten
produzieren molotow-cocktails
reservisten wie hier in der region kiers
trainieren für den einsatz
wir verteidigen unser zuhause deswegen
werden diese einfachen jungs jetzt
eingezogen und das sind große patrioten
sie wissen was zu tun ist und werden den
feind ich stoppen
außenminister kussa wendet sich direkt
an das russische volk
putin hat euch mit in den krieg gezogen
aber ihr müsst dafür bezahlen die ganze
welt hat sich hinter die ukraine
gestellt und ihn zu stoppen ich denke
ihr habt ein einfaches werkzeug diesen
wahnsinn zu stoppen verlangt von putin
den krieg zu stoppen
ein kleiner hoffnungsschimmer an der
ukraine spieler russischen grenze
verhandeln seit heute beide seiten die
ukrainische delegation kommt am mittag
mit verspätung prompt kritik aus moskau
man hätte schon in der nacht starten
können immerhin es gibt gespräche auch
wenn die erfolgsaussichten beobachtern
als gering erscheinen
seit sich der konflikt entwickelt
sterben jede stunde ukrainische
zivilisten und soldaten
wir sind daran interessiert so schnell
wie möglich zu absprachen zu kommen
das hoffen auch die vielen betroffenen
in der ukraine wie die menschen in der
notunterkunft in mariupol
ich sitze hier und bete dass diese
verhandlungen erfolgreich sind dass sie
sich einigen und dass das töten und der
krieg aufhören
damit sie wieder zurückkehren können in
ihr altes leben dass über nacht zerstört
wurde
ja seit fünf tagen tobt der krieg der
alle ukrainerinnen und ukrainer in einen
wahren albtraum gestürzt hat aus dem es
kein schnelles erwachen gibt eine von
innen des julia satzger die in
deutschland studiert hat in der ukraine
als deutschlehrerin arbeitet und uns nun
per skype zugeschaltet ist frau aus holz
guten abend und ja gleich die frage wie
geht es ihnen im moment
guten tag also relativ okay wenn man so
sagen kann also zumindest ich bin in
sicherheit in ruhe im vergleich zu
meine verwandten eltern freunde die ihm
geblieben sind und auch zu den leuten
die in khaki oder person sind ja wo
jetzt
alles läuft es am meisten eigentlich das
heißt sie haben ihren angestammten
wohnort kiel verlassen sind jetzt auf
dem lande in sicherheit wie organisieren
sie jetzt ihren alltag können sie
einkaufen gehen können sie irgendwie
ihrem beruf nachgehen oder ist einfach
alles anders als vorher
das ist natürlich alles anders als
vorher also niemand denkt jetzt über
arbeit sozusagen
alle konzentrieren jetzt auf ereignissen
die mit krieg zu tun sind ja also zum
beispiel hier können wir noch einkaufen
gehen also es gibt geschäfte hier und es
gibt noch genug lebensmittel in kiel zb
die situation ist ganz anders das und
wir denken auch dass wir die männer mit
den autoren mit den autos nach kiel
schicken sollen damit sie levels mieten
und vielleicht medikamente dorthin
transportieren machen sie sich gedanken
darüber was sie tun würden wenn der
krieg jetzt auch in ihre nähe kommen
würde würden sie dann auch wie tausende
ihrer landsleute ins ausland gehen
also erstmal nicht ich denke nicht
gerade im moment darüber ich muss
erstmal hier bleiben und
wissen dass der krieg zum ende ist dass
meine eltern in sicherheit sind und dann
mal schauen
also ich muss auch hier helfen und
erstmal da sein hilft es ihnen dann
persönlich dass ihr präsident sei lenski
jeden tag zum teil mehrere
videobotschaften verschickt zum
durchhalten aufruf dass er signalisiert
die politische führung ist da und hält
ebenfalls durch
ja das hilft sehr sehr also das ist
vielleicht nicht viel leid dass er der
erste präsident denn wer wirklich
verbrauchen können das ist präsident der
für sein volk ist ja also
er verfolgt nicht seine eigenen
interessen sondern interessen seines
volkes also wir haben ihn auch selbst
gewählt mit über 70 stimmen und wir wir
sind sehr stolz auf ihn und das ist
natürlich viel viel ruhiger dass er
jederzeit mit uns kommuniziert und
feedback gibt also er spricht zu uns
mindestens drei vier mal pro tag mit
videoschaltungen ja dass das gibt uns
hoffnung und glaube das alles
wird gut ja dass er mit uns ist ja und
das hält sehr wir sind
letzte frage seine gesandten seelands
kies gesandte verhandeln ja gerade in
bilder russe mit der russischen
regierung was erwarten sie sich von
diesen friedensgesprächen
selbstverständlich wollen wir das
russische feindliche truppen jetzt
endlich unser land verlassen und wir
alle frieden haben
natürlich wollen wir das alles zum ende
kommt aber wie gesagt wir glauben nicht
wirklich daran das ist alles so einfach
und schnell klappt also die russische
seite möchte gar nicht aufhören und wir
können auch sehen dass sogar während der
verhandlung zwischen beiden seiten
der waffen vorher nicht stoppt ja es
noch stärker und stärker
mir wär doch schade dass diese gespräche
jetzt wohl zu ende gegangen sind
zumindest die erste runde und
möglicherweise eine zweite folgen soll
frau solcher danke ihnen auf jeden fall
dass sie ja ihre erfahrungen ihre
erlebnisse im leben ein stück weit mit
uns teilen und uns einblicke gewährt
haben ihnen alles gute und gesundheit
vor allem danke ihn
ergänzen dir mal den blick der
ukrainerin durch den reporter blick
meiner kollegin katrin eigendorf die ja
nun schon seit einigen tagen aus der
ukraine berichtet ihren aufenthaltsort
aber auch aus sicherheitsgründen immer
wieder wechselt katrin wir über die
naheliegende frage zur beginne wie ist
die situation dort wo sie sich gerade
aufhalten
hier ist die situation auch zunehmend
angespannt wir sind zwar hier nicht im
zentrum des kriegsgeschehens die kämpfe
konzentrieren sich momentan vor allem
ganz ganz brutal auf den osten auf die
zweitgrößte stadt charkiw und sie
konzentrieren sich auf kiew aber auch
hier sind die leute im prinzip bereit
sie bewaffnen sich sie haben zunehmend
angst und stellen sich darauf ein dass
es möglicherweise hier einen langen
kampf geben kann wir hören jetzt gerade
aus kiew aus einer pressekonferenz der
regierung dass die verhandlungen zu ende
gegangen sind die delegationen sind
zurück das positive und das muss man
wirklich sagen ist angesichts der
tatsache dass man hier relativ wenig
vertrauen in putin hat und dass die
kämpfe auch heute brutal
weitergeführt werden das positive ist
man will wohl in eine zweite runde gehen
also die gespräche fortführen das ist
wirklich eine gute nachricht an diesem
abend aber im moment sieht die
perspektive nicht gut aus dass man hier
zu einem schnellen ergebnis kommen kann
weil die seiten liegen einfach viel zu
weit auseinander präsident see lenski
hat noch mal ganz klar gemacht seine
forderung ist die russen müssen hier
abziehen und die souveränität der
ukraine muss garantiert bleiben putin
hat ja das werden zumindest die
nachrichtenagenturen als bedingung für
ein ende der inversion eine
entmilitarisierung der ukraine gefordert
auch eine anerkennung der halbinsel krim
ist dann überhaupt vorstellbar dass die
ukrainische führung sich auf so etwas
einlässt
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt halte ich das
nicht für vorstellbar aber es ist
natürlich klar dass auch die ukraine
sollte dieser krieg beendet werden
müssen in irgendeiner form
zugeständnisse machen muss wenn man sich
annähern will und hier nicht auf einen
sehr sehr langen und blutigen krieg hin
steuern will im moment hat die lenski
eine relativ klare position er möchte
dass sein land relativ schnell in die eu
eintreten kann er möchte sich die
perspektive für die nato offen halten
und will dass russland hier abzieht dass
alle besetzten gebiete und dazu gehört
ja auch die krim von den russen sofort
geräumt werden das ist seine bedingung
für diese verhandlungen und man wird
sehen müssen wie man da zusammenkommt
aber im moment ist die strategie der
ukrainischen regierung er dafür zu
sorgen internationale unterstützung zu
bekommen und zu hoffen dass die
russische elite vielleicht putin stürzen
könnte auf ihn einwirken könnte
praktisch welche zugeständnisse lenz
gespräch die ukrainische seite überhaupt
am ende gegenüber russland machen könnte
um eine art friedensschluss zu erreichen
aber ich glaube diese frage kann im
moment keiner so richtig beantworten und
hat eine eigene danke für diese
eindrücke aus der ukraine
von dort aus betrachtet ist moskau sehr
weit weg in diesen tagen nicht nur
geografisch auch emotional die
machtzentrale an der moskwa in der ein
krieg geplant lange geleugnet und
schließlich kaltblütig
vom zaun gebrochen wurde und doch gilt
auch für diese schrecklichen tage an
denen putin und seine getreuen die
waffen sprechen lassen russland ist doch
mehr als ein autokratischer herrscher
russland das sind die menschen die nun
ebenfalls mit den folgen des krieges
fertig werden müssen mit sanktionen mit
währungsverfall und preissteigerungen
und die mal leise mal laut angst haben
vor der zukunft
vor den bankfilialen in der russischen
stadt st petersburg stehen die menschen
schlange sie alle wollen nur eins
bargeld abheben
seit donnerstag rennen alle zwischen
geldautomaten hin und her um bargeld
abzuheben der eine hat glück der anderen
nicht
in moskau ist die lage vor den banken
heute noch ruhig doch die neuen
westlichen wirtschaftssanktionen die den
ausschluss von swift und strafmaßnahmen
gegen die russische zentralbank
beinhalten schicken russlands währung in
den freien fall der rübe verliert am
morgen gegenüber dem dollar rund 30
prozent und fällt auf ein rekordtief die
aktienmärkte in russland bleiben heute
vorerst geschlossen offenbar weil
schwere turbulenzen befürchtet werden
dass alles hinterlässt bei den russinnen
und russen gemischte gefühle
es ist nicht klar wie hier lebensmittel
und andere dinge kaufen werden wenn es
hilft ausgeschaltet ist die
ausländischen waren werden mit karte
bezahlt wie werden wir sie kaufen wir
sind menschen die viele höhen und tiefen
bewältigt haben durch verschiedene
zeiten und wir werden auch diese
überwinden weil es zum wohle der
allgemeinheit ist ich begrüße alles was
putin tut
ja ich bin stolz auf mein land und meine
präsidenten doch es gibt auch andere
laute stimmen wie hier gestern in sankt
petersburg sie rufen keinen krieg jung
und alt demonstrieren gemeinsam gegen
den krieg in der ukraine und auch gegen
putin
der krieg in der ukraine ist nicht unser
krieg es ist der krieg unserer führung
aber nicht unser krieg den krieg zu
beginnen war eine sehr schlechte
entscheidung für unser volk weil viele
von uns verwandte freunde und ehemänner
haben dir sinnlos sterben werden
auch vor der ukrainischen botschaft in
der russischen hauptstadt moskau
bekennen sich russinnen und russen zu
ihrem bruder start sie bringen blumen
zeigen sich solidarisch denn für die
meisten hier ist der krieg in der
ukraine nicht russland sondern allein
putins krieg
fragen wir nach bei anfangs in moskau
lässt sich daran erkennen wohin das
stimmungsbarometer in der russischen
bevölkerung sich bewegt oder ist es so
ja angesichts fehlender unabhängiger
umfragen reinste spekulation
ja es gibt tatsächlich keine richtigen
umfragen hier wir gehen tag für tag raus
und befragen die menschen auf der straße
was wir feststellen konnten ist dass
gerade unter der jüngeren bevölkerung
eine große krieg krieg skepsis besteht
während die ältere bevölkerung auch die
mit so wird hintergrund diejenigen sind
die schon dem narrativ von putin folgen
dass nämlich die ukraine zu russland
gehöre und russland sich jetzt das
zurückholen was ihm zustehe und im
zweifel eben dafür auch mit einem krieg
wobei was auffällt ist dass die dieses
wort krieg vermieden wird stattdessen
wird versucht von einem konflikt oder
das ganze als konflikt zu deklarieren
wir konnten gestern nacht drehen ja
wir konnten gestern nach drehen mit
einer 18 jährigen die demonstrieren war
und bei diesen protesten verhaftet wurde
und mit ihrem vater und der vater sagte
er macht zwar nicht den lauten protest
auf der straße mit aber erst nachts
losgegangen und hat plakate geklebt
gegen putin um ein zeichen zu setzen
weil er sagt das ist nicht sein krieg
die vom westen verhängten sanktionen
dürften ja auch in der bevölkerung bald
spürbar werden der opel fällt schon in
großem tempo worauf stellen sich die
menschen jetzt sein
der rubel ist hier tatsächlich auf ein
rekordtief gefallen nämlich um 42
prozent
als maßnahmen hat die russische
zentralbank den leitzins auf 20 prozent
erhöht und es wurde ein der so genannte
putin erlass gilt ab morgen russinnen
und russen dürfen dann kein geld mehr
überweisen auf konten von sich oder
anderen im ausland damit wird dann de
facto russische kreditschulden im
ausland eingefroren einer noch ein wort
zur ersten runde der friedensgespräche
in gomel die wohl jetzt gerade zu ende
gegangenen sind zumindest die erste
runde putin fordert von der ukraine
offenbar eine entmilitarisierung und vor
allem die anerkennung der krim die jahr
2014 von russland annektiert worden ist
was hört man in moskau über den verlauf
dieser ersten verhandlungsrunde
bisher gibt es wenig meldungen hier
darüber die letzte meldung die eben kam
war dass putin konkretisiert hatte wie
er sich das vorstellen könnte einen
frieden mit der ukraine demnach sagte er
in einem telefonat mit makro dass die
ukraine einen neutralen status bekommen
sollte dass die ukraine komplett
demilitarisiert wird und den offizieren
und dass es eben eine internationale
anerkennung gibt über die russische
souveränität über die krippen und das
heißt die beiden delegationen würden
jetzt der jeweiligen hauptstädte
zurückkehren zu konsultationen mit der
regierung oder den regierungen besser
gesagt und möglicherweise schließt sich
eine zweite verhandlungsrunde an ausgang
offen an erweist dank für diese
eindrücke aus moskau
der vormarsch der russischen
streitkräfte erfolgt ja aus mehreren
richtungen seit letztem donnerstag wird
aber nach wie vor von heftiger gegenwehr
der ukraine gebremste es gibt
explosionen in kiew heftige kämpfe im
osten des landes eine großstadt am
asowschen meer angeblich bereits in der
hand des russischen militärs das ist
eine lage die wie immer ein bisschen
unübersichtlich ist die werber auch
heute mit vier sterne general egon ramms
besprechen wollen gute namen terrence
heute hören wir dazu präsident selensky
sogar anti russischen soldaten im feld
appelliert hat die waffen niederzulegen
hat das auch nur den hauch einer chance
ich denke nein auch wenn ich glaube dass
die moral der russischen soldaten
schlechter ist als die der ukrainischen
soldaten denke ich nicht dass die
russischen soldaten desertieren werden
in einer videobotschaft hat ja sein es
geht darüber hinaus angekündigt
russische kriegsgefangene freizulassen
wenn die bereit sind dann für die
ukraine zu kämpfen ist das wiederum
vorstellbar immerhin müssten die
wahrscheinlich ja mit härtesten strafen
rechnen wenn russland diesen krieg am
ende gewinnt
also das ist sicherlich richtig was sie
gerade gesagt haben dass die eine
aussage und die andere aussage wo ich
mir gedanken darüber mache ist wenn sie
einmal die seite wechseln ob sie nicht
zu einem späteren zeitpunkt zum zweiten
mal die seite wechseln das heißt das
wäre mir als militärischen führer zu
unsicher und aus dem grunde wirklich
einen solchen schritt nicht gehen das
jedenfalls die russischen streitkräfte
die ukraine und vor allem auch die
hauptstadt kiew im handstreich erobern
das hat sich jedenfalls als wunschdenken
des kremls entpuppt der vormarsch der
stock im grunde genommen seit dem
zweiten kriegstag wir haben schon des
öfteren darüber gesprochen wie glauben
sie wird das russische oberkommando
jetzt ja auf diese für sie schwierige
lage reagieren
also die haben die russen nahmen die
möglichkeit und das ist eigentlich auch
bei denen die ich sagte strategie oder
doktrin in einem solchen falle weitere
kräfte einzuführen das heißt es gibt
eine erste zweite oder dritte staffel
auf den verschiedenen operativen oder
taktischen ebenen und ich rechne damit
dass mustern die zweite staffel einführt
oder vielleicht sogar schon die dritte
was mich gestern stutzig gemacht hat war
die tatsache dass der präsident von
belarus lukaschenko angeboten hat auch
mit klassischen soldaten in den krieg
einzugreifen und das lässt eigentlich
auf eine gewisse schwäche schließen von
seiten der russen ich weiß nicht ob man
nicht genügend truppen bereit gestellt
hat und auf diese art und weise wie wir
im fach schöpfung sagen den angriff
nicht mehr aus der tiefen ehren kann
sieht fast so aus
ich glaube dass es viel damit zu tun hat
mit der hohen moral die die ukrainische
soldaten stark zeugen es heißt ja dass
die russen etwa zwei drittel der an den
grenzen
zusammengezogenen truppen bereits in der
ukraine im einsatz hätten aber wenn das
stimmt was sie sagen dann würde das doch
zu einer intensivierung der
radikalisierung der kampfhandlungen in
der ukraine führen unter der vermutlich
auch die zivilbevölkerung weiterleiten
müsste
ja der krieg wird hier intensiver
erwirken wenn weitere staffel eingeführt
werden die dann vielleicht auch den
vormarsch weiter mit gewalt durchsetzen
wollen natürlich schmutziger und damit
leidet dann auch die zivilbevölkerung
deutlich mehr wie ernst nehmen sie die
drogen mit der nuklearen option wie
putin sie gestern ausgesprochen hat mit
der witterung eine kürzere antwort
er hat ja über abschreckungskräfte
gesprochen also die strategischen
raketentruppen oder überhaupt die
raketentruppen können in den alarm
zuständen entsprechend hochgefahren
werden das muss man ernst nehmen wobei
ich auch noch den hinweis geben möchte
man kann diese flugkörper auch ohne
nuklearsprengköpfe mit konventionellen
sprengköpfen einsetzen der
verteidigungsminister der russische
jedenfalls lässt heute verlauten diese
waffen seien nun einsatzbereit was auch
immer das zu bedeuten hat egon ramms
vielen dank wir immer für ihre expertise
danke gerne
bei aller analyse der militärischen lage
darf das schicksal der zivilbevölkerung
nicht vergessen werden sie haben nicht
zu befürchten hatte moskau zu
kriegsbeginn betont aber die zahlen die
die vereinten nationen veröffentlichen
sprechen doch eine andere sprache 102
zivilisten darunter sieben kinder
getötet gut 300 menschen verletzt und
wenn russland seine militäroperationen
verschärft wird es noch viel schlimmer
warnte uno
generalsekretärs der westen hofft dass
die weltgemeinschaft russlands angriff
heute stimmgewaltig verurteilen wird
seit anderthalb stunden takt die un
vollversammlung in new york in einer
sondersitzung
eine sondersitzung der
un-vollversammlung ist äußerst selten in
der geschichte der vereinten nationen
gab es bisher nur zehn mal eine solche
sitzung der un sicherheitsrat kann die
sondersitzung der vollversammlung
einberufen wenn er selbst nicht mehr
handlungsfähig ist zum beispiel weil
seine aufgaben von einer an einem krieg
beteiligten partei blockiert werden so
wie er sonst von russland in der
vollversammlung gibt es kein vetorecht
bei resolutionen eine mehrheit der
stimmen genügt die resolution die hier
beschlossen werden sind zwar nicht
bindend von ihnen geht aber eine hohe
politische bedeutung aus das ziel
diesmal farbe bekennen zur un charta die
einen völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
verbietet und russland zu isolieren und
all diejenigen unter druck zu setzen die
sich bisher bei der verurteilung der
russischen offensive in der ukraine
zurückgehalten haben
wir sind sehr besorgt über die sich
schnell verändernde lage und die
militäraktion in der ukraine wie ich
schon zuvor betont habe die offensive
der russischen föderation verletzt die
territoriale integrität und souveränität
der ukraine und ist unvereinbar mit der
charta der vereinten nationen
un in new york beobachtet johannes hano
dieser sondersitzung der center fast 80
jährigen geschichte der vereinten
nationen ja nur wenige gegeben hat
johannes hatte anderthalb stunden läuft
die debatte lässt sich denn aus den
ersten redebeiträgen schon erkennen wie
sich die staatengemeinschaft heute
zumindest mehrheitlich positionieren
wird
das haben bisher noch nicht besonders
viele gesprochen diese ganze debatte
zieht sich wahrscheinlich über zwei tage
bis alle 193 staaten gesprochen haben
aber eines ist doch ziemlich klar schon
gleich am anfang rausgekommen es geht
hier wirklich ums ganze es geht hier
nicht mehr nur alleine um die ukraine
sondern es geht darum wie unsere
weltordnung in zukunft aussehen wird ob
die charta der vereinten nationen noch
steht oder nicht der parlamentspräsident
der vorsitzende der generalversammlung
hat gesagt der völkerbund habe versagt
um den zweiten weltkrieg zu verhindern
daraufhin seien die vereinten nationen
gegründet worden und das sei jetzt die
aufgabe einen solchen flächenbrand der
sich andeutet zu verhindern das sei die
aufgabe aller mitgliedstaaten der un
generalsekretär hat in die gleiche kerbe
sozusagen geschlagen er hat gesagt
dieser regionalen konflikt könnte sich
sehr schnell in einen großen
internationalen konflikt ausweiten das
müsse unter allen umständen verhindert
werden und putins drogen mit der
atomstreitmacht sei völlig inakzeptabel
es gab dann redebeiträge der ukraine
und hat sich dann daran klar man
ist eine kurze frage noch für heute
abend hat ja frankreich eine
dringlichkeitssitzung des
sicherheitsrates beantragt weil dort
eben auch eine resolution zur abstimmung
bringen ist über den inhalt schon etwas
bekannt
also details jedoch nicht bekannt nur
eins ist klar es wird sich nicht direkt
um eine politische verurteilung des
krieges handeln sondern es geht hier
ganz eindeutig um humanitäre hilfe man
will dass der un-sicherheitsrat
humanitäre hilfe auf den weg bringt
manfort wird eine einstellung aller
kampfhandlungen fordern um der
humanitäre hilfe leisten zu können
seitens der vereinten nationen und man
möchte darauf hinwirken dass keine
zivilen ziele infrastruktur
krankenhäuser mehr in diesem konflikt
mit hineingezogen werde genaue text
liegt noch nicht vor und versucht gerade
alle auf die seite zu holen eine
resolution die möglicherweise dann aber
wieder am veto russlands scheitern
könnte johannes danke für diese
auskünfte an den hudson river ja der
un-generalsekretär ätherisch warnte vor
zunehmenden menschenrechtsverletzungen
im ukraine krieg litauen wird der
konkrete und fordert heute sogar den
internationalen strafgerichtshof wegen
russischer kriegsverbrechen und
verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit zu
ermitteln in berlin begrüße ich norbert
roth können mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss des bundestages guten abend
zurück einen guten abend wenn wir da
gleich mal anknüpfen sollte sich
deutschland nicht einer klage gegen
russland in den haag gleich anschließen
es liegen ja ganz eindeutig
kriegsverbrechen vor schon der
angriffskrieg er ist ein
kriegsverbrechen und nun stellen wir
fest dass
russland gezielt zivilisten so
bombardiert dass gezielt zivilisten
dabei zu tode kommen und verletzt werden
und das sind eindeutige kriegsverbrechen
vladimir putin betätigt sich als
kriegsverbrecher durch den überfall
durch den angriff und durch die art der
kriegsführung und das sollte auch von
allen zum beispiel europäischen
regierungen auf der bundesregierung so
klar gesagt werden und das hat auch dazu
geführt dass die vorher vor dem deutsche
zurückhaltung gegenüber moskau nun
tatsächlich der vergangenheit angehört
schärfsten sanktionen gegen russland
sind in kraft waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine auf dem weg das sollte jetzt
alles ganz schnell gehen manche sagen
aber doch das kommt alles zu spät um die
ukraine zumindest militärisch zu retten
es kommt spät ich glaube nicht dass es
zu spät kommt vor allen dingen auch weil
die ukrainische armee
herausragendes bewundernswertes leistet
in ihrem widerstand auch weil die
russische armee
offensichtlich nicht keine gute moral
hat was aber auch zum teil was für die
soldaten spricht sie sehen auch nicht
ein in größerer zahl dass die ukraine
töten sollen sie sind schlecht
ausgerüstet haben kein essen und so
weiter das heißt dort geht es langsamer
ukraine leistet beachtlichen widerstand
ich glaube wenn jetzt
sind ja schon eingetroffen
materiallieferungen defensive waffen
werden ein weiterer großer zahl kommen
das wird den widerstand verlängern der
ukraine gegen die russen gar keine
fragen und darum wird es auch wirken das
material aus deutschland um fast 500
stinger raketen 1000 panzer abwehrwaffen
war das jetzt eine einmalige lieferung
oder wird beziehungsweise muss
deutschland auch weitere tranchen
liefern und das wichtigste was in
deutschland geschehen ist sind das
unsere grundsätze sich geändert haben
die ja sagen in stein gemeißelt schienen
und jetzt hat sich die wirklichkeit so
verändert dass diese grundsätze an der
wirklichkeit gescheitert sind und wenn
man einmal sich auf die wirklichkeit
einstellt dann wird man das auch
weiterhin tun und möglicher und dann
auch gegebenenfalls und darum ist das
glaube ich aus meiner sicht der erste
schritt und weitere wenn geboten werden
vorher trotzdem röttgen hat man ja ein
bisschen den eindruck er ist jetzt da
der russische vormarsch ins stocken
geraten ist der legt sich deutschland
für die ukraine ins zeug es scheint als
sei der erfolg des ukrainischen
widerstands ja fast eine art
vorbedingung gewesen für tatkräftige
militärische unterstützung die jetzt
erfolgte hat das nicht doch einen
bitteren beigeschmack nein das finde ich
nicht das finde ich nicht fair jetzt
hier der regierung eine derartige
position zu unterstellen weil das
nämlich zynisch wäre das liegt nicht vor
es ist zu lange gebraucht worden ich
habe ja seit seit anfang der letzten
woche als krieg war so lange verhandelt
wurde habe ich gesagt lasst uns keine
chance vertun aber als klar war es wird
krieg durch nach den hasserfüllten reden
von putin hat es zu lange gedauert
deutschland hat sich in eine also
überall tage lang in eine isolation
innerhalb des westens begeben mit
außenpolitischen schaden
das war zu lange hat schaden verursacht
aber jetzt ist korrigiert worden aber
nicht weil
der russische vormarsch stoppt und weil
sich die militärische lage so entwickelt
hat das nicht und der ukrainische
präsident des elends gedenkt jetzt sogar
schon über diesen krieg hinaus erfordert
einen eu beitritt im eilverfahren
kommissionschefin ursula von der leyen
sagt die ukraine die gehört zu uns wir
wollen sie bei uns haben sind das jetzt
hirngespinste angesichts des tobenden
krieges oder im gegenteil sind das
perspektiven die man jetzt schon auch
mal gegenwärtigen sollte ich glaube dass
es wichtig ist dass wir uns jetzt
absolut fokussieren auf das worum es
geht nämlich die vernichtung die
zerschlagung der ukraine als
eigenständigen staat zu verhindern wenn
wir das nicht schaffen dann gibt es gar
kein mit gibt es gar kein staat mehr der
der mitglied werden könnte und darum
geht es darum militärisch wirtschaftlich
finanziell geostrategisch alles zu tun
damit die ukraine überlebt der krieg
beendet wird und die ukraine als
unabhängiger staat überlebt und dann
gilt ihr auch weiterhin jede
unterstützung die sie auch vorher schon
geleistet haben noch mehr nach dieser
erfahrung ich glaube es geht jetzt darum
die ukraine darin zu unterstützen
von großen träumen in der zukunft glaube
ich das hilft jetzt im moment keine
deutliche worte des cdu
bundestagsabgeordneten norbert röttgen
ich danke ihnen für das gespräch großer
nach berlin ich danke ihnen sehr größe
nach mainz im zuge der russischen
invasion sind ja bereits mehr als eine
halbe million ukraine in benachbarte
länder geflohen das hat heute uno
flüchtlingskommissar filippo grandi auf
twitter bekannt gegeben damit ist die
zahl der geflüchteten allein seit
gestern abend um 80.000 gestiegen ganz
zu schweigen von den menschen die im
lande selbst umherirrenden verzweifelten
bemühen den kampfhandlungen irgendwie zu
entkommen ihr leben zu retten die
meisten flüchtlinge haben sich bislang
ja nach polen aufgemacht gut
280.000 zelt der polnische grenzschutz
ohne männer ohne väter werden sie die
ukraine verlassen es sind wieder
bedrückende szenen auf der ukrainischen
seite am grenzübergang zum polnischen
medica männer zwischen 18 und 60 jahren
dürfen das land nicht verlassen sie
sollen kämpfen
nur die kinder und meine frau gehen ich
kehre nach lewis zurück in den krieg
stundenlanges warten an den übergängen
zu polen bei minusgraden bis sie es
später schaffen über die grenze
wir sind vier stunden gegangen 20
kilometer die autoschlange ist wirklich
lang weil
noch kommen züge an aus der ukraine am
polnischen grenzbahnhof in chemische die
züge in den frieden für tausende seit
donnerstag gestrandet am bahnhof nur mit
dem was sie tragen konnten manche haben
verwandte in polen andere wissen nicht
wohin unzählige polen wollen helfen wie
der notorische
wir haben zimmer ein eigenes haus wir
suchen nach einer mutter mit kindern die
wir aufnehmen können
von überall kommen mittlerweile menschen
nach polen bewegt vom schicksal der
flüchtlinge matthias kim ist aus hamburg
angereist will menschen mitnehmen ihnen
unterkunft anbieten
ich will nicht dass jemand auf dem
fußboden schlafen muss keine mutter mit
kindern wer einen anderen krieg ist
allein heute sollen 28.000 vor allem
ukrainerinnen mit kindern in polen
angekommen sein wer nicht von
privatleuten aufgenommen wird wird hier
erstversorgt und ist immerhin in
sicherheit
ich brachte das kind her weil ich angst
habe ich kann nicht mehr länger in
kellern sitzen
die hilfsbereitschaft ist groß polen
kümmert sich um die flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine seit tagen eine dramatische
situation wird allmählich zum traurigen
alltag
und polen ist nicht das einzige ziel
ukrainischer flüchtlinge knapp 85.000
sind nach ungarn ausgereist rund 32.500
nach rumänien und 30.000 in die slowakei
am slowakischen grenzübergang vision die
metzger beobachtet dritter hinter den
strom der ankommenden dritter er reißt
nicht ab oder
nein er reißt nicht ab der strom das
muss man sagen aber auch wenn dieser
absperrgitter zeigen eines es läuft
jetzt organisiert habe dort hinten wo
die flüchtlinge über die grenze kommen
hat die slowakei jetzt sogenannte
hotspots aufgestellt dort können die
flüchtlinge sofort einen längeren
aufenthalts titel und eine
arbeitsgenehmigung beantragen außerdem
sieht man ihr helfen die soldaten
natürlich und die leute können hier bei
verschiedenen organisationen oder auch
privatleuten die sich hier organisiert
haben unterkünfte anfragen transport
anfragen kostenlosen transport
selbstverständlich der sie weiterbringt
auffanglager oder in städte wo sie eben
verwandte oder freunde haben weiter
inland gibt es auch bereits auffanglager
zelt steht aber auch container dörfer
entstehen wo es warm ist es trocken ist
wo die leute sich auch erstmal ausruhen
können oder auch längere zeit bleiben
können und mein eindruck ist hier heute
abend dass der takt sich viel schneller
tatsächlich es heißt drüben auf der
grenze müsse man nicht mehr so lange
warten und jetzt kommen immer mehr immer
schneller die gruppen in immer kürzeren
abständen welche zukunftspläne abenden
die geflüchteten wenn man überhaupt von
kleinen entsprechen kann wir wollen die
in der slowakei bleiben oder doch eher
in andere eu länder weiterreisen
da gibt es sag ich mal wie im wesentlich
zwei unterschiedliche gruppen es gibt
die die verwandte oder freunde in der eu
haben die erst mal dorthin gehen und die
hoffen dass das nicht lange dauert das
tun natürlich im übrigen alle dass das
nicht lange dauert aber die die
verwandte und freunde haben die haben es
natürlich leichter fuß zu fassen jetzt
kommen aber immer mehr leute die
vielleicht am anfang gezögert haben weil
sie nicht wussten wohin und die dann der
erste schrecken des krieges tatsächlich
vertrieben hat und diesen menschen zu
helfen dafür ist jetzt hier auch massiv
mehr organisiert worden die armee ist
hier vor ort die polizei hat verstärkt
wie gesagt zelte aufgebaut und alles und
diese leute werden dann weiter gebracht
in lager weitergebracht an orte wo sie
hoffen dass sie hier aufgenommen werden
eine neue migrationswelle die auch
europa vor neue herausforderungen stellt
und über die die europäischen
innenminister am donnerstag beraten
werden dritter danke für diese
beobachtungen von der slowakisch
ukrainischen grenze
ja wenn sie liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen dann ja öffnen sie bitte
großherzig ihren geldbeutel spenden sie
an das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine
die iban nummer lautet de 65 104 106 100
104 106 100 alle informationen auch
unter spenden zdf de im internet oder
schauen sie in unseren zdf text auf
seite 8 190 dort können sie noch einmal
alles in ruhe nachlesen
ja karneval ist heute auch rosenmontag
aber karneval und krieg passt das
wirklich zusammen das passt nicht und
daraus haben die kölner karnevalisten
schon am tag des kriegsbeginns am
donnerstag konsequenzen gezogen sie
haben den heutigen rosenmontagszug
abgesagt und stattdessen eine
friedensdemonstration
angekündigt denn das was wiederum
trefflich zusammen passt gegen entgelt
in diesen tagen umso mehr karneval als
ausdrucksform der kritik an der
obrigkeit die russische obrigkeit die
bekommt dementsprechend ihr fett weg
es ist kurz vor neun hat sich der
chlodwigplatz in köln füllt auf den
ersten blick ein wunderbarer rosenmontag
will verkleidete narren strahlend blauer
himmel und es werden immer mehr doch es
geht nicht um karneval in diesem jahr
soll eine friedensdemo werden gegen
putins angriffskriegen der ukraine und
für ein ende der kämpfe
ich habe freunde in der ukraine die
gerade versuchen mit ihren familien zu
fliehen die den karneval genau so sehr
lieben wie ich den die wir uns hier ein
zeichen zu setzen zu sagen ganz klein
steht die ukraine ist mir extrem wichtig
meine möglichkeiten sind begrenzt
deswegen ist die teilnahme an einer
solchen demo für mich heute der einzige
die einzige möglichkeit ja letztendlich
ein zeichen zu setzen gegen diese gegen
diesen krieg aber vielleicht aber auch
wenn man jetzt sieht was in der welt so
alles an widerstand passiert auch hier
heute vielleicht ist das auch als
zeichen eines von ganz vielen kleinen
puzzleteilen die vielleicht irgendwas
bewirken wie ist das für sie heute am
rosenmontag bei so einer friedensdemo
mitzumachen es ist ziemlich unwirklich
um ehrlich zu sein weil man sieht
überall in der stadt die ganzen
kostümierten wie es halt normal ist bei
uns hier in der ecke und trotzdem es ist
aber schön zu sehen dass es einfach sehr
viele leute sind die super ernst nehmen
und die auch einfach sehr betroffen und
sehr ernst mit dabei sind das ist schön
zu sehen kurz danach auf der bühne statt
und bundesprominenz wie zum beispiel
papstar wolfgang niedecken ich finde
diese idee
den rosenmontagszug aber höchsten kölner
feiertag zu einer friedensdemonstration
zu einer solidaritätskundgebung um
touren zu leeren dermaßen charmant ich
glaube das kann zeichen setzen hat sich
der zug in bewegung durch die kölner
innenstadt setzt noch niemand
diese demonstration noch werden wird die
komplette zugstrecke von rund
viereinhalb kilometern ist gefüllt das
festkomitee kölner karneval spricht am
frühen abend von mindestens 150 tausend
teilnehmern viele integrieren das sind
ihre carnevals pläne sind verkleidet und
gehen später noch in die kneipen weiter
andere sind extra für die demonstration
nach köln gekommen all das ist kölsche
protestkultur an rosenmontag unterdessen
in düsseldorf hier hat wagenbauer
jacques tilly quasi über nacht noch
einen mottowagen gebaut und lässt ihn
heute durch die straßen fahren auch hier
klare kante gegen putin wir zeigen
natürlich erst einmal die situation dass
er dabei ist die ukraine zu verschlucken
mit seinem riesigen maul her aber
gleichzeitig kommentieren wir das und
wünsche neben erstickt dran um zu zeigen
halt hoffentlich wird das eben für ihn
politisch katastrophal enden bis zum
späten abend will die durch die straßen
kreuzen oder muss die batterie leer ist
zurück nach köln hier läuft der zug
immer noch mit dabei inzwischen auch
nrw-ministerpräsident hendrik wüst der
rosenmontag ist eigentlich ja ein tag
der freude in köln heute ist es eher
getragen ein wunder wie karneval mit
gezogenen stecker aber ein sehr sehr
starkes zeichen viele hunderttausend
menschen die sich solidarisch erklärt
mit der ukraine nicht ein zeichen setzen
gegen den krieg sehr gute stimmung mit
ein bisschen stolz auf meine leute hier
nordrhein westfalen es ist ein besonders
emotionaler augenblick ich bin schon
häufig mit dem rosenmontagszug gegangen
zu fuß aber
das hier heute die zivilgesellschaft so
mitmacht und ihre solidarität mit der
ukrainischen bevölkerung zeigt das finde
ich schon bemerkenswert und es genau das
richtige signal heute eben nicht zu
feiern sondern zu sagen es ist krieg und
wir gehen für den frieden auf die straße
auch in köln gibt es am zugweg
motivwagen auch hier sitzt eine ganz
klar auf der anklagebank aggressor
wladimir putin der mit cora gewalt die
sowjetunion wieder auferstehen lassen
ganz am anderen ende nordrhein
westfalens haben heute 70 künstler die
gesperrte autobahn brücke der a 45 bei
rahmen genutzt um ein zeichen zu setzen
mit insgesamt drei tonnen farbe werben
sie für den frieden
in köln wird sich der zug wohl erst in
den abendstunden auflösen insgesamt
sollen dann rund
250.000 menschen teilgenommen haben an
diesen beeindruckenden solidaritäts
zeichen für die menschen in der ukraine
ja spaß haben denn keine 2000 kilometer
von uns entfernt menschen sterben darf
man das haben sich wohl auch die
närrinnen und narren gefragt und wie wir
soeben gesehen haben haben sie ihre
wagen und motive angepasst und mit
klaren botschaften auf putins beutezug
zu reagieren dafür hut beziehungsweise
narrenkappe ab
das war unser zdf spezial das nächste
folgt um 19.30 uhr geht es weiter mit
der soko hamburg auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
bleiben sie immer aktuell informiert im
zdf und der zdf-reihe app
machen sie sich bereit
eine neue folge soko hamburg